what is c4c far is inspiration
stimulating is energizing
interdisciplinary environment where
people have true conversations well I
sometimes think of it as the gifted
program for the smartest people in the
world I think it's a community of
scientists that if you like celebrates
the process of doing good science and
bringing it to the public in ways that
are meaningful practical useful and a
lot of fun our mission is to bring
together the best Canadian researchers
with the best researchers in the rest of
the world to answer complex questions
which are at the edge of human
understanding questions that the answers
to which will change the world will
change the way we see the world the way
we adopt the world the way we understand
the world's a lot of levels at which the
work of sefa is incredibly important I
think the most obvious is just that
they're a providing support for research
that otherwise wouldn't be done and they
bring together they mobilize teams that
wouldn't otherwise be working together
turns out that forty percent of c-4
people are in the top 1% of their field
of study what does that mean it means
that their work he is used by other
researchers to think with there is no
single University on the planet of which
that could be set and see far as among
if not the only organization that can
bring the big big minds together we
answer really profound questions about
the nature of the planet the universe
life human society and Pima development
I think sefa is video unique institution
I think it's a great shame that we don't
have anything like that in Britain I
don't know of anything like that in the
United States or in Australia or other
countries that I've worked those of us
in the CFR program are right at the
leading edge of the world in this thanks
to the quality of this network and the
opportunities for us to network through
it to see them in action gives me great
hope for
for the future of this country and the
world because they are really smart
folks doing some really wonderful things
you